tout le monde le porte le jean et la
petite poche à l'avant sur le côté
coincé dans la grande elle sert à quoi
nous nous sommes toutes et tous posés au
moins une fois la question pour répondre
nous allons faire un petit voyage dans
le temps direction le Far West américain
il y a 160 ans à l'époque le jean est un
vêtement de travail robuste pas cher et
plutôt confortable très vite il est
adopté par les bûcherons les ouvriers
les mineurs et les cowboys nous sommes à
une époque où la montre bracelet
n'existe pas encore on porte la montre à
gousset reliée par une petite chaîne
cette petite poche permet donc de ranger
sa montre sans risquer de la perdre ou
de l'abîmer on l'appelle même la Watch
pocket depuis la petite poche est restée
même si les montres à gousset sont plus
rares on lui a trouvé d'autres usages on
y range des pièces des clés ou des
préservatifs dernière anecdote le jean
que l'on appelle de Nîmes tient son nom
de la ville de Nîmes en France mais ça
je vous le raconterai dans une autre
vidéo